what's going on guys this is rob and
while we're all excited for the what if
series there is
one episode in particular that's gonna
change everything
see i think most of the what if series
is just gonna focus on interesting
what-if stories t'challa becoming
star-lord different things along those
lines
but the episode with peggy carter is
going to be nuts and here's the reason
why so the premise behind the peggy
carter episode is that
peggy ends up being the one to take the
super soldier serum instead of steve
rogers and this leads to her becoming
captain america or technically captain
britain as she's supposed to be called
because she's british and she has a
super soldier serum and that's basically
it
whether or not we end up seeing britain
developing the super soldier serum
instead of the united states
we'll just have to wait till the episode
comes out to find out but the idea is
that she's going to be operating under
the mantle of captain britain
there's another character who operates
under the mantle of captain britain and
you've heard of him before in fact
you heard his name dropped in avengers
end game his name
is brian braddock that's the reason why
so many people were excited
what's the significance behind captain
britain let's look at marvel comics for
a second
in marvel comics captain britain belongs
to a larger group called the captain
britain court
and the whole idea behind this is that
these guys basically exist to protect
the multiverse from various threats that
exist
out there they suck and they really
can't do it effectively mostly because
they're not all that powerful when you
have a guy that can fly and he can punch
really hard he's got some measure of
durability
he's painfully weak in the face of
someone like the marquee of death
who can wipe out whole universes with a
wave of his hand
guys totally unnecessary to say nothing
of the fact that captain britain would
probably get
pummeled by somebody like thanos but the
important thing here is
that's the role they play why do they
play that role because the captain
britney four was created by a guy named
merlin and his daughter named roma
technically it was merlin first and then
roma who continued it but the important
thing here is that merlin is exactly who
you think he is merlin from arthurian
legend king arthur knight to the round
table
all that kind of stuff they basically
exist in a place outside of all time and
space
similar to the way the tva existed this
is where things get really interesting
here
the whole idea behind the captain
britain core is that when a person is
selected
they are given two options the first is
the amulet of right or the sword of
might
more often than not merlin and roma
focus on those individuals who choose
the amulet of right
because that's basically a person who
does things under logic reason
and is a true champion a person who
chooses the sword of might
just wants to destroy stuff and so
they're usually not chosen to become a
captain britain
even though they are allowed to keep the
sword the important thing here is that
when a person chooses the emulative
right they go on to become a member of
the captain britain corps now
i don't think that selection process is
going to be introduced in the mcu
why because it's overly complicated and
in reality it's unnecessary
it was cool but it was never really a
necessary thing
instead what you actually have going on
right now and something that you have
had going on in marvel comics for a very
long time
is a woman by the name of saturnine or
saturn depending on who you're talking
to
saturnine exists in a place called the
starlight citadel
and this is by all standards of
measurement the base of operations for
the captain britain court
they don't really operate out of it per
se they all exist in their own universes
and they can access the multiverse by
way of something called the lighthouse
which exists on the coast in
england but if something pops off on a
multiversal level and they all have to
meet together
they all meet the starlight citadel now
the cool thing about this is that you
can look at the character of saturnine
and you can kind of package it all
together in a pretty small and
interesting way
right we already know by virtue of loki
the multiverse is back we've seen a lot
of those videos where they actually tie
the return of the multiverse into the
events of one division and you kind of
have that moment where wanda is
officially becoming the scarlet witch
that coincides with the moment when
mortis says we've crushed the threshold
a lot of you guys have already seen
those videos a lot of you guys are
already aware of them meaning the impact
of the multiverse reforming
is really a result of the scarlet witch
that once wanda became that character we
crossed the line that we couldn't come
back from
and it all just kind of popped off from
there but the important thing here is
you can look at this idea of the war of
kings
that all took place before the
multiverse form and all that kind of
stuff and say
that around that time the starlight
citadel and saturnine existed and the
captain britain corps was there
and it wouldn't be that hard to take the
captain britain corps and tie it
in and say they were the part of the war
of kings that they were fighting on
behalf of the good kings the ones who
didn't want to conquer the multiverse
and that despite it all
they were all basically destroyed
defeated whatever the case happens to be
much like they were destroyed and
defeated during the incursions during
jonathan hickman's avengers new avengers
run one of the best stories ever
but the funny thing about this is that
in the modern era right now in fact in
the x-men comics
saturnine has brought back the entire
captain britain core without the
selection process of the amulet of right
or the sword of might meaning
they can just kind of be arbitrarily
chosen and so the way i think this would
play out in the marvel cinematic
universe
is you basically have this idea that
with the war of kings the
entire captain britain core was
destroyed saturnine was doing whatever
it was that she was doing maybe just
kind of operating in retreat or just
kind of staying in silence
waiting for the time when the multiverse
would come back and now that it's
here she alongside so many other people
are now making their moves
that the super evil version of kang went
back in time ensured that he was the one
that won the multiversal war and created
the tva
hence the reason why you see kang at the
end of the loki series instead of
immortus and the time keepers
but also the idea that the captain
britain core is now being reformed
by virtue of the fact that all these
kings are back because we have to
believe
that if the multiverse was a source of
all these different versions of kang
and it led to a giant war among all
these kangs that nobody who survived the
experience
would be preparing for that that nobody
surviving the experience would say okay
what if the multiverse came back we have
to believe that there are other people
out there that know the stories of
scarlet witch
nexus events different things along
those lines and they had to be preparing
for the idea that at some point it may
return
at some point the scarlet witch may take
her mantle and then the multiverse will
end up returning
and everything will just kind of come to
a head and it'll start all over again
and so the captain britain core
returning is a great way to tie into
that
it's a great way to bring those things
together something else to keep in mind
here is that yes we were told at the end
of loki that the multiversal war was
a war of kings but i have a hard time
believing it was just
kang's fighting kings that surely they
had like entire forces conscripted into
their service
that if this is a conflict that led to
the destruction of an
entire universe it would take more than
just two guys getting into a fist fight
you understand what i'm saying
the amount of energy it takes to destroy
an entire universe
is huge let alone the amount of energy
it would take to destroy an entire
multiverse so there's not really
anything to indicate that if these kangs
were going back and forth in their own
timelines and it would lead to the
destruction of their universes
it would just lead to more universes so
there had to be some kind of a massive
conflict between these different kangs
and presumably all the forces they had
at their disposal that led to the
destruction of the multiverse
i honestly think that included groups
like the captain britain court and so at
the end of that what if episode with
peggy carter
i wouldn't be surprised if she ends up
basically traveling to the lighthouse
and then entering the lighthouse or if
she's met by saturnee possibly merlin
roma or even other members of the
captain britain core that basically take
on this kind of perception the same way
that nick fury did at the end of the
first iron man movie
and telling peggy carter you're stepping
into a much bigger world here
surely you didn't think you were the
only person across the multiverse
to ever become captain britain we're a
giant team
welcome to the club something along
those lines i think that's a great way
to kind of sync all this stuff together
and so going forward you would likely
see something akin to like the
spider-verse where you have like
a whole bunch of different spider-man
from other realities all teaming up
you would see that in the future of the
mcu you would see peggy carter captain
britain along with maybe a version of
steve rogers who was born in britain
and ended up becoming that universe as
captain britain in mobile comics you've
got spider-man uk
so basically william braddock a guy who
gained the powers of spider-man
and then became captain britain just
things along those lines this is the
benefit of having the multiverse back
there's an endless number of
possibilities all kinds of things can
take place
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section regarding this
stuff because here's one thing to bear
in mind
is that not to put too fine a point on
it but a mortise was kind of right when
he said we've crossed the threshold
right here in the real world
with the introduction of the multiverse
and the marvel cinematic universe you
can't come back from this
and the threats are wide and varying we
already know that schuma gorath is
supposed to be in doctor strange too or
at least
that's what the news is saying anyway
all the different reports and so on and
so forth
shumogorath is part of the many angled
ones the many angled ones are basically
the ones that exist
between universes and shumagorath in
particular
has had a very fond interest in
conquering the main marvel universe at
least in the comics
but in the comics themselves he's
conquered multiple realities there's
entire universes all of which are ruled
completely
by shumogorath the main marvel universe
is just the next step
in this whole idea of conquest so
there's all kinds of things out there
that marvel can use on a multiversal
level that's not even including villains
like the marquee of death mad jim
jaspers matthew malloy
the character of protege who can copy
the powers of anybody he sees
there's all kinds of things out there i
mean how far-reaching they'll get
probably won't be that extreme right the
marvel cinematic universe really
predicates itself on focusing on real
tangible things
things that are kind of a reflection of
the real world but nonetheless
i think a lot of these possibilities are
really there and i love the idea of the
captain britain core
because one of the benefits here is it
can allow marvel to bring back
characters
that we thought were long since dead i
doubt they'd be able to get robert
downey jr to come back as iron man or
even as a british version of iron man
for like
you know some version of captain britain
from some alternate reality but we could
see it in a future what if animated
episode
that's the cool thing about this that's
a great possibility about these things
is that
if the captain britain core really is
returning we may not necessarily see it
in a movie form
but we could certainly see it in an
animated form right like a captain
written animated show
similar to what if that's the
possibilities here guys there's a lot of
great things that can come out of this
so
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section let me know if you
guys are excited for this idea of the
various forms of captain britain the
captain britain core
a multiversal team that exists to face
off against all these different threats
possibly even having faced off against
the various kings that existed out there
and the multiversal war from loki all of
which were destroyed and now the team's
in the process of being reformed
hence the reason peggy carter would be
inducted onto the team let me know what
you guys think about this i feel like a
lot of this stuff is really cool but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace